[Applause]
so I have just been at Fox's tour Fault
in Our Stars movie featuring shailene
woodley Ansel Elgort and NAT Wolff
pictured here dancing getting psyched up
for the show the tour started in Miami
where everyone dramatically
underestimated how many people would
show up which led to big AV problems and
crowd control and generally I'm just
very sorry but lessons were learned and
everyone was much better prepared in
Cleveland where several thousand people
wanted to say hello to you Hank
we were also reunited with some of our
friends who played members of the
support group in the movie all of whom
have lived with cancer and we got to
hang out with youtuber Eva Lena berry
who is our awesome co-host on the tour
oh it's the smile that slayed a thousand
parts and that wolf had to get up very
early the next morning to get my hair
and makeup done it takes a lot of work
to wrangle the puff and then I had many
many hours of interviews hey Chris choke
and interviews are weird cuz you talk to
a new TV interviewer person every five
minutes for like hours it's really hard
to talk meaningfully about like anything
because one you only have five minutes
and two they have to get their quotes
and three you've been asked the same
question a thousand times before and for
I was really worried about saying
something stupid and or insensitive
balls of I knew if they made me keep
talking I would eventually get the husky
voice and I have anyway I realize I'm
winning like an Olympic gold medal for
the first world hiest firstworldproblems
my point is that it was hard to engage
on the upside sometimes we got goodie
bags with treats in them I think the
best part about being on tour with
someone who doesn't eat processed food
is that you get shailene Woodley's
googoo clusters anyway then we went to
Nashville a lovely town where there was
this red carpet like thing and lots of
people to sign for which is great but
also weird because I would like to stop
and talk to them and have as near a
normal interaction as possible given the
circumstances but there were these large
men on both sides of me pushing me along
and lots of screaming and just in
general the whole situation was no more
conducive to meaningful conversation
than press junket Senna did a few red
carpet interviews again difficult to
feel connected to the world / the actual
people in it and then we went inside
where NAT and Alex Wolff were playing a
concert Shailene and I lay down on the
floor
and peeked under the curtain to watch
also there were quite a lot of people
there who wanted to say hi to you next
morning more hair more makeup and many
more hours of press before going to down
with where there was another red carpet
and more screaming in bodyguards and
more interviews and then many thousands
of people who get this ank wanted to
wish you a good morning I was so
grateful to have this time to see so
many nerdfighters and to talk about the
movie with the actors who helped make it
so special but I also felt really
disconnected like with all these people
from the outside paying attention to us
I felt really self-conscious as a
nerdfighter like it was hard for us to
be a community together which is what I
love most about nerdfighteria and I was
feeling pretty bummed out about it and
then so I'm during these events people
could ask questions and a young woman
named Caroline came up and introduced
herself and talked about how she's found
The Fault in Our Stars helpful as she
lives with lymphoma
she was pretty emotional as we talked in
so was I so was the cast and then
suddenly thousands of people in the
crowd began chanting her name I realized
I could even if we're gonna be
scrutinized for a while by people who
don't know if nerdfighters fight for or
against nerds nerdfighteria is still
nerdfighteria I realized the community's
never really been about us Hank it's
been about having big conversations
around big questions and lifting up
people who need it so I want to say
thank you nerdfighters from Miami to
Dallas and everywhere in between for
welcoming new people but also sticking
together thank you for lifting each
other up and for decreasing Salkin for
increasing awesome when I'm very far
from home and feel very disconnected
from my real life you guys helped me to
feel like I am not so far from home
after all so thank you I love you
not you Hank everyone else all the other
people actually you know what hank god
help me i even love you
by the way and congrats on your album
being a huge hit on the itunes charts
it's so great everyone get it Hank I
will see you on Friday when I will be
home huh dftba